president biden trying to change the
topic after the chaotic afghanistan
withdrawal by focusing his efforts on
fighting kovit and his massive 3.5
trillion dollar spending plan bynan is
set to give a major address later this
week on the next phase in his pandemic
response as well but republicans are
saying that's so fast
i understand the administration wants to
turn the page they want this out of the
news they want to focus on their
reckless three and a half trillion
dollar spending bill but there's a lot
of members of congress who are not going
to rest until every american and every
legal permanent resident in afghanistan
can get out of afghanistan and vice
president kamla harris will be out in
public this week too but not to talk
about afghanistan the vp will be in
california tomorrow helping governor
gavin newsom because there's a recall
election there happening next week jesse
president biden all he wants to do is
build back better yeah
i mean he's just like can we just just
build back better that's what he wanted
to do and remember he said i want to
talk about happy things that's right
happy things you can't shift the focus
if you're joe biden he was never focused
on afghanistan in the first place if he
was focused on afghanistan we wouldn't
have lost face
lost marines and lost all those weapons
he wasn't even focused on afghanistan
while he was giving a speech
on afghanistan remember dana before i
update the american people on
afghanistan build back better the media
doesn't have to do what joe biden wants
to do the media can focus on what they
think the action is going to be donald
trump do you think they let trump turn
the page
on covid
they asked him he talked about tax cuts
what do you think about russia you don't
have to do what the president wants to
do see the democrats they let democrat
the media lets democrats turn the page
but they'll close the book on a
republican and that's how this works the
media is in bed with biden if biden goes
down the media goes down because the
democrats go down they know his poll
numbers are horrible they those are
their own media polls and if he goes
into the 30s and doesn't get this
infrastructure thing done then the
midterms are going to be more of a
bloodbath than they're already shaping
up to be so they're going to say
which is damning we're going to ignore
stranded americans in afghanistan and
the fact that the president is
considering
turning the page on stranded americans
like you said in the a-block that means
he sees these stranded americans as a
political problem for himself not a duty
or a priority to rescue so you know
he'll spend this 3.5 billion and turn
the page but he'll only get credit
trillion for inflation
well there's that as well and uh he
brought up the poll numbers greg it used
to be for
a few months the the president's worst
numbers were on immigration and they
were really bad like in the 30s but now
he's upside down on afghanistan covet
economy
crime and immigration
that's not a good trajectory yeah
everything he touches turns to poop you
know um i just want to i want to talk
about the recall that excites me can i
talk about it because i just want to put
a block no no no kamala
is going to help him out isn't that part
of this block
that was in the ability i heard it in
the wreath
is kamala harris the worst vice
president in the history
of vice presidents right
well
we've had some bad news it is the d
block you know what though she has all
the fun
sending kamala to help gavin is like
asking charlie sheen to be your sponsor
at aa this is not a good decision she
has the persuasive skills of doubt she's
able to do two things peop that no
person could possibly do be invisible
and unpopular like flatulence she's
political flatulence
[Laughter]
she is the cackler in chief i have no
idea why this woman why they're even
asking her to go there who's excited
about seeing her she hasn't done
anything she hasn't been present on any
of the issues i mean look at mike pence
i mean that guy was he was he was every
day he was on something he was working
he was on this issue or that issue he
was always moving this woman is hiding
in a basement she's probably at joe
biden's old house and meanwhile joe
biden by the way is it death you want
him to deal with afghanistan the guy
keeps going back to delaware i don't
know what's wrong with him even during
afghanistan he went back this weekend he
wants to talk about the economic the 3.5
trillion dollar uh
economic build back better he can't
possibly build back better we're
supposed to have a great jobs report
we're supposed to have 750 000 new jobs
on friday we had 200 000. the guy is a
mess and she's a bigger mess well one of
the things that the president did today
was go and visit storm damaged areas new
jersey and uh new york he was in
louisiana last week so hurricane ida did
provide an opportunity for him to be
commander-in-chief to try to help people
that are dealing with that but on all
those issues
would you say
is an issue that's going well for them
right now
i think that as we have vital national
security interests we have vital
national interests and this president i
think is understanding and realizing the
rhythm of a presidency he is down right
now in a lot of the numbers you you
indicated there was this there was a
decision by the governor of texas to to
try to rewrite abortion laws and
reproductive rights laws which may shift
some of the attention as things do in
politics
i'd say this i gave president trump
tremendous credit for operation warp
speed uh i was critical of him in other
ways and how he handled kobet i think we
have to be willing to give presidents
credit where it's due and be critical
where it's not and understand that any
president and we'll say she one day
he is going to understand what's going
right and try to figure out how he can
continue to amplify that and at the same
time he has a responsibility to respond
to ida he has a responsibility to try to
ensure that we can compete against china
and i would remind us all of this
a year and a half ago at this time we
were not producing enough soap or paper
towels in our country we now have a chip
shortage and can't produce enough
washing machines refrigerators and cars
because we have no chips we ought to
figure out ways in which two years from
now we're not having to be reliant
on a on a global supply chain for us to
live our everyday life sounds like that
has to be trump policy but you didn't
answer the question harold what was the
thing that joe biden's doing well right
now
well i think i think i think i think
he's being president i think he's being
mature i think he's being responsible i
think he's he's making clear i will be
accountable is it mature to strand
americans at the war zone a hundred is
that a side of maturity 120 000 people
got out of there jesse we will find out
what went wrong and we will hold those
people accountable but i give them a lot
more credit today than i did back on
august 24th i don't give them all a
credit they certainly will be criticized
and held accountable for the mistakes
they made and there were many harold i
i'm just offended that you use the
cisnormative pronoun when talking about
she becoming president you felt that
right i was like can we just say they
they i mean i honestly i thought we've
moved beyond these like bigoted i picked
up on that channel yeah me too i don't
know if i can even sit at this table hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else